ahora que ya montamos la parametrización
vamos a intentar calcular la integral y
lo siguiente que vamos a intentar hacer
es expresar a este señor de ese en
términos de nuestras de eeuu y debe ok y
entonces de ese sólo hay que recordar
que de ese de ese no es otra cosa más
que la norma o la magnitud del producto
cruz de hereu con r&b donde hereu y r&b
son las derivadas parciales de nuestro
vector de posición respecto de un y
respecto de b
ok ahora yo yo puse la doble barra
porque no me quiero confundir con el
valor absoluto hay gente que pone solo
una barrita para denotar la magnitud o
la norma aquí vamos a utilizar la doble
barra y falta multiplicar por dv
dv ok entonces vamos a calcular primero
este producto cruz para ya ir
continuando con el cálculo formal de la
integral entonces este producto cruz
como lo puedo
calcular pues simplemente es como un
determinante verdad digo que no es
insisto un determinante si no es
simplemente notación que nos ayuda a
recordar verdad esto simplemente es el
determinante poniendo en la primera fila
los vectores canónicos y jk y en la
segunda vamos a poner las coordenadas de
hereu pero rv derivar esto de aquí
arriba respecto de v entonces la primera
respecto de eeuu es uno la segunda
respecto de v es cero porque sólo tiene
b y la tercera respecto de v es uno muy
bien estuvo muy sencillo ahora eso fue
hereu vamos a calcular ahora rb quien es
r b pues ahora derivamos respecto de b y
en la primera nos queda 0 en la segunda
nos va a quedar 1 y en la tercera si
derivamos respecto d b
éste se anula y nos queda la derivada de
b cuadrada que es simplemente
muy bien entonces ya tenemos esta matriz
y ahora simplemente hay que calcular su
determinante quien sería el determinante
de esta cosa de género poniendo ok
entonces para calcular el determinante
primero empezamos con el vector y
quitamos su columna y su renglón y nos
queda esta sub matriz a la cual le
sacamos el determinante entonces sería 0
por 2 b 0 - 1 por 1 que nos queda menos
1 y eso corresponde al vector y entonces
nos queda menos menos y vámonos ahora
con el siguiente que es jota pero como
vamos es el segundo la segunda columna
que tomamos le corresponde un signo
ok aquí déjenme poner j y ahorita vemos
por cual hay que multiplicar entonces
quitamos el renglón y la columna
correspondiente a jota y nos queda 110 2
b a estos que nos quedaron hay que
sacarles otra vez como una especie de
determinante entonces es 1 por 2 b que
es 2 b -0 por 1 que es 0 entonces nos
queda simplemente 2 b que multiplica
nuestro vector canónico j y ahora nos
tomamos el vector k ahora sigue el
vector k que hay que multiplicarlo por
si quitamos el renglón y la columna
correspondientes acá pues nos quedan
simplemente estos 4 numeritos que si
sacamos el determinante pues es 1 por 1
1 - 0 por 0 0 entonces así es como me
queda expresado el producto cruz ahora
este es apenas el producto cruz nosotros
necesitamos calcular la norma por lo
tanto déjenme
y ponerlo así esta norma esta norma se
calcula de la siguiente forma
va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada ok de
la suma de los cuadrados de cada una de
las entradas verdad entonces fíjense en
la primera en la primera yo simplemente
tengo menos 1 que elevado al cuadrado es
1 en la siguiente entrada tengo menos 2
que si yo lo elevó al cuadrado me queda
4 b cuadrada entonces vamos a sumar aquí
4 b cuadrada
aquí quizás debo reescribir bien la vez
que parece un poquito pero bueno ahí
está y ahora la caja la que tiene sólo
uno verdad aquí es un uno que si lo
elevamos al cuadrado nuevamente me queda
uno entonces esto es la magnitud de ese
de ese vector es la magnitud entonces
simplemente ya resumiendo aquí podemos
agrupar estos unos y me queda la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de uno más uno
que es 2 + 4 b cuadrada
dv
bebé muy bien ahí incluso esto lo
podemos ir simplificando un poco más
porque si aquí adentro factor izamos 12
nos queda 2 que multiplica a 1 + 2 b
cuadrada
bebé y este 2 lo podemos sacar de la
raíz verdad es decir lo podemos sacar
así la raíz de 2 que multiplica
multiplica a la raíz de uno más 2 de
cuadrada dv desde muy bien entonces ya
tenemos hecho esto y ahora si ya estamos
listos para calcular con todo la
integral la integral original que
teníamos acá arriba que es la integral
de leyes sobre la superficie entonces
cómo hacemos esto bueno esencialmente
déjenme poner primero lo que ya tenemos
de firme hacerlo con morado voy a poner
esto que es la raíz de 2 por la raíz de
uno más 2 b cuadrada
dv
bebé y ahora hay que multiplicar porque
verdad aquí está y que multiplica de ese
entonces ya le dijimos que era b
entonces aquí simplemente va una b
entonces éste corresponde allí y déjenme
poner que todo esto todo esto
corresponde a de ese muy bien entonces
lo que hay que hacer ahora es integrar
integramos esto respecto del primero
entonces déjenme poner esto más bien con
con verde
dv
y esto lo integramos con de 0 a 1 y
luego integramos integramos la vez de 0
a 2 que es en donde están definidos
estos parámetros verdad entonces fíjense
muy bien que esto morado que puse lo
puse morado porque sólo depende de b en
realidad se puede salir de nuestra
integral entonces simplemente nos va a
quedar la integral de 0 a 2 de d
y déjenme poner primero la constante la
raíz de 2 por b por la raíz de 12 b
cuadrada ok y luego sigue la integral la
integral de 0 a 1 dv
y eso respecto de be ok esta ya queda
dentro de esta integral y todavía podría
sacar esta integral verde porque es una
constante de esta integral morada pero
no hay necesidad porque si nos damos
cuenta esta integral simplemente vale 1
ok entonces realmente esto se simplifica
muchísimo se simplifica muchísimo a este
raíz de los lo puedo sacar esto sería la
raíz de 2 por la integral de 0 a 2 de b
lo más acá db por la raíz de 112 de
cuadrada de b
perfecto entonces esta integral ya es
bastante sencilla fíjense que en
realidad sólo es un ejercicio de
sustitución porque si nos damos cuenta
lo que está dentro de la raíz lo que
está dentro de la raíz es 1/2 de
cuadrada y su derivada es 4 b aquí ya
casi tenemos 4 b excepto que me hace
falta el 4 entonces lo que puedo hacer
es multiplicar aquí por 4 pero para que
no se altere la igualdad
tengo que dividir nuevamente entre 4
entonces ahora sí ya tenemos muy bien
que esto es la integral de de esta raíz
de esta función que afuera está su
derivada entonces esto lo podemos tratar
como si fuera una equis verdad es decir
esto podríamos pensar que estamos
integrando la raíz cuadrada de x verdad
y que esto como es x ala un medio y al a
integrar simplemente tenemos que hacer x
a la un medio más uno que es tres medios
entre el exponente que queda aquí o que
es lo mismo que multiplicar por dos
tercios entonces lo que vamos a hacer
aquí la equis vale 12 b cuadrado verdad
es desde el principio de la sustitución
entonces esto simplemente es 1
1 2 b cuadrada todo esto a la 3 medios a
la 3 medios y hay que multiplicar por
dos tercios por dos tercios ok todo esto
vamos a evaluarlo de 0 a 2 esto de 0 a 2
y hay que multiplicar por esto de aquí
afuera que es raíz de 2 raíz de 2 sobre
4 2 sobre 4 de hecho déjenme déjenme
sacar esta constante de dos tercios esta
constante déjenme la sacó y la pongo de
este lado multiplicando y aquí podemos
darnos cuenta cómo simplificar porque
aquí este 2 se puede ir con uno de estos
dos del 4 y nos queda simplemente 2
entonces aquí es algo que ya hemos
llegado
esto será igual a la raíz cuadrada de
dos sobre dos por tres que son 6
sobre 6 que multiplica a quien a esto
primero evaluado en 2 entonces y
evaluamos en 2 aquí es 2 al cuadrado es
4 por 2 819 y luego si le sacamos raíz
cuadrada eso será 3 y elevado al cubo
eso es 27 27 y ahora si evaluamos en 0
todo esto se cancela y me queda 1 a la 3
medios que es 1 entonces restamos 1 y es
hora de empezar a escuchar el redoble de
los tambores porque esto simplemente es
26 por la raíz de 2 sobre 6 y que
todavía podemos simplificar más sacando
mitad tanto arriba como abajo y esto
sería 13 la raíz de 2 sobre 3 y hemos
terminado